.
C'est à peu près impossible. En
plein désert.
- Quatre jours après s'être
échoué, le Ever Given n'a pas
bougé, malgré l'opération de
dragage et de remorquage.
EMMANUEL GUY, prof. transport
maritime, Univ. Qc à Rimouski
- La grande inconnue
à ce moment-ci, c'est :
est-ce que le dragage autour
de l'avant du navire va suffir
ou est-ce qu'il faut alléger
le navire. Et s'il faut aller
vers une opération d'allégement
de navire, donc de déchargement
partiel de sa cargaison,
ça va prendre plus de temps.
- Faudra-t-il des jours
ou des semaines pour déplacer
le cargo de 400 m de long
et de 220 000 tonnes qui
bloque le canal de Suez.
Une route commerciale cruciale
entre l'Europe et l'Asie,
où transitent plus d'un milliard
de tonnes de marchandises
par an, soit 10 % du commerce
maritime mondial.
De forts vents et une tempête
de sable auraient causé
l'incident. Depuis, c'est
tout le secteur qui tourne
au ralenti.
Les répercussions sur les coûts
sont inévitables, croit
cette experte, qui rappelle
que le transport maritime nous
apporte encore 90 % de tout.
Surtout que des centaines
de navires tournent en rond,
coincés, forcés d'emprunter
un détour vers le cap
de Bonne Espérance.
Des milliers de kilomètres
pour contourner l'Afrique.
- Ça représente un ajout de
6 à 7 jours sur un voyage qui
peut durer près de 3 semaines,
dépendamment des escales, etc.
Donc, c'est quand même
conséquent et si ça perdure,
ça va mettre une pression très
importante sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement, surtout
pour les marchés européens.
- Des marchés déjà mis à mal
par la pandémie. Le blocage
du canal de Suez a aussi fait
monter les prix du pétrole.
Une raison qui a poussé
les États-Unis à offrir leur
aide aux autorités égyptiennes
pour éviter que la situation
s'éternise.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, M